as i went down in the river to pray
studying about that good old way and who
shall wear
the starry crown good lord
show me the way
oh
sisters let's go down
let's go down
come on down
as i went down in the river to pray
studying above that good old way and who
shall wear
the robe and crown good lord show me the
way
oh
brothers let's go down
let's go down
come on
down
oh
brothers let's go down
down in the river to pray
as i went down in the river to grace
good lord show me the way
oh
fathers let's go down
let's go down come on down
oh
fathers let's go
down down
the river to break
as i went down in the river to praise
good lord show me the way
oh
mothers let's go down come on down don't
you wanna go down
come on mothers let's go down
down in the river to pray
as i went down in the river to pray
studying about that good old way and who
shall wear
the robe and ground good lord
show me the way